did you use like a moving company the
first time you moved
yeah i got a moving company but i mean
the the moving company we're using for
now the new places like
has like a service where like they'll
come in and like pack it for you like
weirdly enough the moving company is
probably the easiest thing to sort out
yeah okay when moving it's everything
else that's a pain like
the intel internet is the [ __ ] worst
i can imagine like setting up internet
for a new place is
that's hard in the uk as well yeah it's
like the hardest one yeah because
they're just like they're just
like oh yeah so uk going uh four months
without internet in the new place it's
like
no no i'm [ __ ] not yeah but at least
without current price like they'll give
us like a like a kind of portable
or not portable but like a rental wi-fi
kind of thing so you're not like
completely out of internet you're just
like
yeah it still sucks that i have to wait
for like the full price to like kick in
but
yeah yeah i mean yeah the moving company
is weirdly the smoothest
thing sick yeah awesome i remember in
the uk when i moved
all my stuff to my parents house um i
again i was trying to do it as cheap as
possible yeah and there was like a
service
that had like vans but for uber
any van or something in the uk right
right paid a guy uh
guess how much i it costs to go
basically from
london to north wales like that's like
basically half the uk
right how much think that cost to hire
that van like like one van
just one guy in a van just driving
normally i'd think maybe like
i don't know 300 pounds maybe there's
120 pounds i think i
i paid that sounds as [ __ ] and i was
so [ __ ] scared the whole time when i
put my
because this guy was just like right
what are we doing what what we put in
the boxes what are we doing what are we
doing
it was just like some guy who just like
again again like uber for fans
wow it was really nice my mum was like
yeah he was really nice when he got
there
i was like that just sounds like it was
so cheap and i was like this guy can't
be getting much so i gave him a fat tip
because
he was really nice and was really
helpful uh to my mom that sounds scary
though doesn't it like that's weird that
just calls for some dude
who has all your stuff in his van and
just drives off yeah this is the middle
of nowhere
there was a gps tracker on his car but
again he could just take it oh you
weren't with him
no oh okay oh that's more scary
gave him all my all my valuable stuff
he's like see you later
jesus christ so your laptop your pc yeah
everybody everything
that's scary yeah and somehow we fit all
our van and everything and
uh yeah somehow it was fine and it the
service was great paid
it was pretty much cheap as [ __ ] yeah
jesus i'm thinking i'm like the fuel
must have been like
half of that cost like this this man
cannot be getting any money from yeah
yeah that's why i was like
fat tip yeah he might be living just
strictly off tips yeah i don't know [ __ ]
i feel bad but yeah i mean i don't know
like because like tipping culture
i don't know timmy culture is different
everywhere in the world right and
in the uk it's uk is like kind of in the
middle i guess
with tipping culture um japan is
non-existent which
you know there are there are times when
i wish that i could tip people in japan
yeah because i get some of the best
customer service here that i've ever had
worldwide and i can't tip people here
it's because it's the whole philosophy
of you know
the best customer service is expected
wait what was the tension that we were
on before i started talking about my
event
your movie company right yeah moving
cars i basically just said the moving
company was
doing it oh yeah sure when i moved in
the uk from london back to brighton like
just use gumtree
and i i feel like we've with the uk um i
i don't know anyone who's actually used
the moving company everyone's just
knowing a mate whoever yeah
at least one friend has like a giant
yeah
i mean that's just pretty our age but i
think when the people use moving
companies are like families yeah just
absurd amounts of stuff that makes sense
i mean i was because
at my age i i when i moved out i
recycled or threw away
probably about 70 percent of my
belongings anymore yeah yeah
but like because i was like oh well i'm
you know i i like uh
i put everything on f for free on
gumtree all my stuff
come get it who wants who wants my
wardrobe who wants my [ __ ] oh yeah
that's what i did with like
without car movies as well there's like
a japanese site where you can just throw
like couches and beds
yeah right people just come picking
people on like craigslist like [ __ ]
exactly give things because throwing out
trashy costs [ __ ] money yeah and like
an absurd amount of money to throw out
where i'm just like
why would anyone do that in the end just
give it to someone